[Music]
we are here at Benihana I am here with
Chef Devin he is a master teppanyaki
chef he's gonna teach me how to become a
true master chef first things first you
want to put on your uniform your apron
your chef's hat
[Music]
I'm official is how we're gonna do it
I'm gonna start by practicing some
tricks then I'll put my skills to the
test and finally be judged on how well I
brought so I'm gonna show you some
tricks you want to try flipping the
spatula is this sharp a little bit there
we go
the trick is just moving our whole army
to
[Music]
let's move on
watch me hit my face it's sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you want to see the butterfly soy sauce
a little sodium maybe a high sodium any
other known for dad joke show you how to
make a beating heart smell it now you
have to do it to people my friends don't
kill anybody
I welcome you all to this journey of
mine on becoming a master teppanyaki
chef I hope you're ready for an epic
teppanyaki meal let's do this
what am i doing
I'm gonna show you a magic trick you see
this butter she's gonna become a butter
fly
please enjoy super-good I'm serious
I've never had vegetable that tastes
okay a little bit oily yeah I'm gonna
pour LeBron James has been amazing I'm
just thrilled can't wait for those you
see my arrow trick this is what dreams
are made of
Chris my childhood my child your child
is my cheddar what do you talk about I
hate more rice than you oh it's my
favorite trick yet here's an egg I'm
gonna perform some magic make it into an
egg roll don't raise a gorilla I don't
want to get that you know I'm making an
omelet what cuz on the lid
she is very good at seasoning
[Music]
he makes way more noise
[Music]
that's it guys the course is complete
now it's time for the real test a lot of
good jokes a lot of good tricks I'm
going to give this a massive thumbs up
this shrimp was succulent the mushroom
was magnificent the rice was just ah
woohoo think of you move to a crazy were
hilarious I give it up and now my final
judge a worst enemy as much as I hate to
admit it she's a great job so no she's
still better you passed the test
I now present you with this certificate
and iw master teppanyaki chef thank you
for everything you taught me I will hold
this title with pride and I would do the
teppanyaki world proud
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part